so tomorrow or or probably next week I
will have a report for you about the
legal challenges that are already
starting for the midterm elections that
are 12 days away yeah they're doing it
again there's no question that they're
doing it again we've already seen a
number of legal challenge challenges
start and if you want to sort of get a
jump on that story you can Google it and
you'll find some examples Fox News
propaganda Tucker Carlson is doing
something very dangerous and I fear and
I believe that the fear is a very
rational and sober fear I fear that they
are going to be doing 2020 all over
again where they are priming the right
wing and the pro-trump people are
priming their audiences and their voters
to believe if we lose
it must have been fraud
and they are priming them to be angry to
the point where they may again become
violent here's a clip from last night's
Tucker Carlson propaganda show on Fox
News
where he is in an overtly dangerous way
starting to say listen some of these
people if they supposedly win they
definitely didn't and you should be
ready for that then he brings on Glenn
griftwald to talk about it which we
won't be looking at it keeps working
it's not about the person it's about the
party it's not about the individual it's
about the group
and to prove it they can even run
mentally defective candidates you can
barely speak now by the way when he says
mentally defective candidates who can
barely speak
we know he's talking about John
fetterman but fetterman's not barely de
fact mentally defective fetterman had a
stroke and as an auditory processing
issue and it's abundantly clear when you
see fetterman right
that he can absolutely uh uh make the
case as his doctors have that he has his
mental faculties in place
Tucker should be talking about Herschel
Walker but he's not
but he's talking about fetterman okay
let's continue with the video I'll go
back a moment mentally defective
candidates you can barely speak and not
only expect them to win but expect you
to accept the outcome no matter how
transparently absurd it is
on November 9th they'll be telling you
that John fetterman got 81 million votes
in Pennsylvania and they'll threaten to
put you in jail if you don't believe it
why wouldn't they do that it worked with
Joe Biden
Glenn Greenwald is independent
journalist his work is on substation yes
sub stack okay so candidates that can
barely speak he should be talking about
Herschel Walker he's talking about John
Federman Tucker just makes things up and
the line that he is implicitly going
with here is elections we lose are
rigged that's the name of the game and
this the groundwork was laid in 2019
into 2020
they tried it in 2020
they may have got been able to get away
with it in some localized instances
which fortunately they did not but they
got close enough to stealing some
electoral votes that of course they're
going to try it again and the name of
the game now is
if we lose it was rigged and if we win
we say nothing at all look at what was
happening in the Arizona gubernatorial
race where it was a close race carry
Lake ultimately won
when it looked like Kerry Lake was down
by a little bit
she and others immediately started with
the voter fraud claims irregularities
here early voting problem there mail-in
ballot problem here and on and on and on
and then she ended up winning by a
little bit and they basically shut their
mouths about the fraud if you ask them
they do have a ready-made explanation
and the ready-made explanation is well
there was tons of Fraud and attempts to
rig it we just won by so much that even
with the fraud we ended up winning by a
little bit
that's their explanation and of course
it is unfalsifiable we are soon going to
be putting out a really good white paper
guide sort of thing it'll be free to
everybody in our audience of how to
approach people when they make claims
like this how can you start and and kind
of have a conversation where you agree
on
what is it we're trying to figure out
and how do we determine what is the
truth and one of the things that that
guide is going to include is a sort of
um uh not a warning a sort of notice
that when the standard is one that
depends on you to falsify something
that's not falsifiable
it's not even really worth getting
involved and what I mean by that is
the voter fraud election fraud it was
rigged people they can always say you
haven't definitively proven to me that
there was no rigging and of course if
there is no rigging it's hard to prove
definitively that there was no rigging
because there's an absence of evidence
for rigging that's it burden of proof
has been shifted and so it's really
important to consider is the standard of
proof that someone else is putting out
an impossible standard to me because I
can go to them and say okay
um the number of registered voters and
submitted ballots perfectly aligns with
the state's population age demographics
for how many registered voters there
could be historical turnout that all
looks fine
the uh anecdotal reports of specific
fraud double voting dead voters Etc
we've run them down and found that they
are without Merit so we have no reason
to believe that there was election fraud
here and they'll say you have not proven
to me what about that claim and that
claim and that claim an increasingly
unbelievable claims so it's very
important at some point to be able to
understand the burden of proof you were
claiming something that is not supported
by the by the data and is an
extraordinary claim that all of the
results we have reflect the wrong winner
per the will of the people you have to
prove it at some point the burden of
proof has to be on them and
unfortunately when Tucker just goes
listen they're going to make you accept
that candidates who can't speak got a
ton of votes it's just it just doesn't
work he is priming these folks
dangerously to reject losses as fraud
and it could it's we know it can get
very ugly look at 2020 okay lawyers
losing their licenses violence death
okay we know it can get very ugly and it
may again get very ugly
I'm a big gardening guy many of you have
seen the videos we have a lot of fun
with it on social media and the crucial
thing to any Garden is nutrient-rich
soil provided by composting composting
your food at home means you don't need
chemical fertilizer it also reduces
methane emissions from landfills it
reduces your carbon footprint the big
downside is that it can take over a year
for food waste to fully decompose but
not when I have a low Me by our sponsor
Pella Lomi is a countertop electric
composter it turns food into fertile
dirt in under four hours no smell when
it runs it's super quiet and it means
I'm throwing out less garbage I'm saving
space in my trash can outside the trash
can no longer smells like rotting food
since it all goes in the loamy the
benefit benefits of the loamy just go on
and on I'm so glad I have one I know you
will be too and you'll get fifty dollars
off when you go to loamy.com Pacman and
use the promo code Pacman but do it fast
they're already eighty percent sold out
for this month sometimes they're
completely out of stock the link is down
below